the idea of the equator to pop what's
the point when you think of that
projectile motion right you get a very
predictable shape when you look at this
to establish that it is exactly what you
think it is you need some algebra right
so you've got parameters and we need to
get rid of them now to give you a bit of
a parallel to this we're very used to
getting rid of parameters right which
topic do we mostly do with parametric
soon in mixed answer mostly we're
thinking about just parabola so you're
actually used to this locus of the
parabola right now to this guy you can
read focal length and the weather
directrix is and so on and so forth ok
now the parameter is teeth how do I go
about in this case how do I go about
getting rid of tea what do we actually
do you matey the subject of one of the
equations clearly X is going to be the
better choice okay you take that guy you
sub him into the other one and then out
pops this equation which lower horn has
no more parameter in it right so you've
got parametric equations and you've got
this Cartesian equation right by default
for all kinds of standard sorts of
projectile motion questions which have
an initial velocity V and an initial
firing angle angle projection alpha okay
you're going to get the same X dot and
why God sorry x and y every time right
what are you going to get x is easy
first because there's no acceleration
acting right what do you get there you
get V T cos alpha remember it right
depending on what your initial velocity
and angle are you get some concrete
numbers in there okay in exactly the
same way I'm going off just depending on
what gravity they give you either 10 or
nine point eight I'm you're going to get
minus now what I have a pier what I
started G
II do you swear on to write because of
those two integrations right and then
you've got the initial upward velocity
right yeah okay now admittedly this
looks a lot more messy than this because
you've got trig functions and then all
that but that's okay because the trig
functions are just numbers depending on
what alpha is of course so it looks
worse it's not really okay now what's
the clue that tells you these are
related to each other and we'll give you
a parabola not just because it looks
like it but algebraically what's the
what's the signal that tells you it's
the T squared isn't it that guy right
there that's how you know it doesn't
just look like a parabola it really is
one and that's when you get this result
from which is written in a couple of
different ways okay you get this
sometimes you'll get that in terms of 10
squared it doesn't really matter there
you go so if you like there's your
Cartesian equation in X and y no time
involved okay now I want you to try
using this for this question number 7
that I've given you okay you can see
that this kind of equation is going to
be more helpful to you if all you're
really interested in is where things
happen okay if you need to know anything
about when they happen you have to
appeal back to these equations right if
you have a look at question and all the
different pieces have nothing to do with
time it's just about where the things
occur where am I going to be highest
where am I going to end all those kinds
of things this is a far more elegant way
to go about it there are less equations
to worry about